some sounds are so wonderful that you
just can't get enough of them like the
roar of the bmw x6m eight cylinder high
performance engine
bmw's constant please says that after
the success of the first generation of
which they sold almost 20 000 units in
five years it was time to bring out a
second even better generation under the
hood you'll find the latest generation
m2m powered turbo engines with 4.4
liters of cubic capacity and 8 cylinders
it boasts 575 horsepower 20 more than
the previous generation and 750 newton
meters of torque that's 70 more than
before
the car flies from zero to 100
kilometers an hour in just 4.2 seconds a
full half second less than its
predecessor prix says that's true sports
car level
that's impressive considering that this
car is 4.9 meters long and has a hefty
curb weight of 2.27 tons bmw says
average fuel consumption is 11.1 liters
per 100 kilometers so it's a bit of a
gas guzzler but then the x-6m doesn't
aim to be an eco-friendly model it's a
car that combines extremes and pushes
boundaries
carson pre says they've made lots of
modifications to the chassis and drive
train to make the car more agile precise
and rid of some characteristics typical
of sports activity vehicles so the
vehicle doesn't understeer its
performance is very neutral he believes
the x6m unites all the precision and
predictability you'd expect from an m
model
like its breathtaking sound the other
sporty details suit the x6m well
in particular its coupe like silhouette
transforms it into a premium sports
activity vehicle or sav
side gills with air breathers reduce
turbulence in the front wheel arches
at the back a rear spoiler helps lessen
aerodynamic lift and drag
from behind the new x6m also looks more
dynamic and pleasing than the standard
version
carson says that with the new x6m bmw
once again aims to appeal to performance
oriented people
with a car of this class they can
express that more than they might
ordinarily
he feels that this makes a very strong
statement about people their performance
orientation and their taste in design
inside everywhere you look the x6m is a
little more luxurious a little sportier
a little more extravagant
to achieve optimal acceleration from a
standing start the driver activates the
launch control function which has been
adapted from race cars drivers depress
the brake pedal while stomping on the
gas until they reach the ideal starting
rpms
once the driver takes his foot off the
brake the car shoots forward as fast as
possible
carson free says the new bmw x6m will be
sold worldwide but they expect the main
markets to be the us china russia the
middle east canada and germany
its sound looks and performance are out
of this world but hearing that the x6m
starting price is almost 118 000 euros
in germany it's enough to bring most
buyers back to earth fast
you